let's jump off the top of this to the
ground i do parkour it'll be fine it'll
be fine i don't think a stuntman react
episode has ever been my palm sweaty oh
my god this next bell is it's the most
ridiculous thing
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end so you can
find out how to get 25 off each pair of
sneakers
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntman react we are here
with jesse laflaire hi jesse hi
jesse is a parkour man extraordinaire
and jesse's gonna break down some of the
crazy things that human beings are
capable of well select human beings are
capable of doing also we got clinton
here welcome back clint so let's just
jump into it guys
[Music]
so a lot of people have recommended that
we take a look at store which is a
parkour team and
they've mentioned that the store they
worked with michael bay for the one of
the sequences in six underground i mean
probably multiple parts of this movie
but we're gonna take a look at this
pretty crazy parkour sequence
[Music]
whoa
that's so cool
i nearly got permission to do this i'm
running on the side of this thing i'm
assuming he must be on a wire right yeah
and physically that's no how else would
he
[Applause]
[Music]
where's he going was he just flying
through the air i'll just jump off the
top of this to the ground i do parkour
it'll be fine it'll be fine
we're working on a michael bay film with
six underground you might have heard
that store they're from the uk group of
friends became a really really powerful
team notoriously known for their povs so
anyone that doesn't know that most of
this stuff is mouth mount mouth mount so
you're essentially either holding the
camera directly or they make little like
scuba gear like mouth things that you
can screw a gopro or insta 360 camera on
it's also worth mentioning that when you
do have a mouth mount in it limits your
ability to like
see your feet
[Music]
this looks so sketchy
well i mean the little edges on this
thing you're talking about like you clip
a toe that's a hard thing to save not to
sound like an old man
the stuff like that is like they're
pushing risks so far especially in a
public area how does one responsibly
free run yeah i think from a pro's
perspective they've won they've tested
this they've done it the big thing that
people get injured on a lot is not
testing the surfaces like dust i know
that especially this or the other povs
when they're running from security look
like
they're just
winging it but it's they've calculated
everything they've felt everything as
long as you're respecting yourself and
you're respecting
others property that's it
[Music]
i'm trying to clear a gap in roofs like
this is it better to aim for the top
jump like that or is it better to do the
jump like this guy's doing the cat hang
that you just saw is that's always kind
of a backup right like realistically
it's almost safer to actually do the
precision to the edge
so yeah you can see his feet right here
where they're landing right on the ball
of the foot and what most people would
assume if you were to do this without
any skill you'd like i don't want to
land on the edge with my toes on the
actual edge of the roof i'm gonna land
with my whole foot there but the problem
with that is when your foot's on top of
something and your momentum is going
back even if you're leaning a little
this can slip once this slips you're
falling there's nothing to save you but
if i jump with my foot and let it land
on the edge and roll up this this gives
me the ability to one scrub some
momentum off where i'm actually pulling
it through plus if i didn't make it now
i'm hitting something controlling my
weight and then dropping into that cap
nice i'm always surprised at the natural
precision that the human body has it
seems like we're very much like
programmed to be able to land these
things more so than we think would you
say that's the case or
you know do you feel like it's something
that really takes time to hone in on it
i think it's definitely the case most of
the time i think obviously we're talking
about extreme scenarios here so you'd
want to know how to do it a little bit
better than just relying on that but our
bodies are so in tune with like our
peripheral like vision it's like we take
for granted so much of what we're
capable of seeing when we're still
looking ahead and watching something
else
and so you have arrived the sun is
setting and your story is about to begin
huge announcement we've been working on
this project for months and it's
dropping next week son of a dungeon is
coming out the story is amazing sam
weaved an incredible tale the chancellor
of sports has given you an emergency
call the vfx for real-time green screen
work with unreal engine the whole
thing's just a wild ride
23 points of damage
oh my god the first episode is going to
be dropping here on this channel
corridor crew you can watch all the rest
of the episodes on quarterdigital.com
that's right next week
[Music]
so jesse do you think that getting
injured is just a part of the job of
being a parkour athlete in some ways you
have athletes like there's a guy named
dom tomato who he went from like being a
pretty good athlete to being one of the
best athletes in the world right now
because he
constantly is eating
like bailing hard hardest battles in
parkour
oh he got lucky always smiling he got so
lucky like some luck but he's still
hitting the ground yeah you're right
jeez dude so one of the big problems
about doing front flip precisions
precision when you land precisely onto
something or punch phone out of it is
that when you front flip your rotation
is coming over you so you're you're
blind your body's blinding you
to where your feet are going so it's it
the calculation has to happen on takeoff
damn
that's a gap dude that's also like sharp
edge brick like there's i know it sounds
weird but there's like differences
between concrete and pavement there's
difference between like the slight edge
of a brick like that's some sharp edge
brick that'll rip your shin apart oh my
god this next bell is it's the most
ridiculous thing this is the middle of a
he's competition going he continued to
go
the way he pops up he's like that hurt
but it doesn't hurt yet
yeah i can just see the pain you're
going
like that slight pause when he comes
around that thing you can already tell
like oh that that did hurt and he
doesn't work trick is like yeah this is
really hurting i'm gonna stop
it's like the clip of the guy trying to
do the nunchucks then he goes to the
backflip but like
and then he's like
[Laughter]
yeah so that's called getting lost
he absolutely thought the ground was
where we are and uh had no idea he was
about to land see he opened thinking
this should be the ground
yep that's me
you're probably wondering how i ended up
in this situation
do most parkour people fall as much as
he does um no
that's i think that's a pretty easy no
[Laughter]
how far of a drop do you think you could
comfortably take like that that lip back
there
like feet on top of the rail is probably
too high right no
standing on top of that rail
and jumping outward and then like
dropping into a roll so your feet hit
and pushing into a roll possible 100
like if you asked me for a movie like i
wanna do we need it with no pads i'd be
like
let's do it
[Laughter]
this is abc's wide world of sports
stigma falling
let's take a look at like the highest
fall uh jesse i know you're not
necessarily a high diver but there's
this clip that's on youtube of rick
charles doing the world record high dive
which is 172 feet
oh my god
what
like that pool is probably like
wide as hell but looks like nothing dude
is there a priest here is there like a
coffin down there just in case he's
never done this before he does not know
what to expect he's in the areas dude
jumped up an extra foot
he didn't hit well
dang
wow they had the hose to soften the
water dude the fact that he
jumps
that's how confident he is
i'd be like sitting on it like lower
myself as much as i can
so why flip at all i mean it's a great
question i think honestly it allows you
to have something to control if if he
were to just a pencil dive down there's
no way to come back from that right if
you're just slow like oh even if you're
trying to back pedal there's nothing
controlled with a flip his ability to
talk
spot and then open is actually the thing
that's allowing him to be able to
control the braking pattern right so he
is now very he's opening open and
opening seeing the body goes where the
head looks so as he turns his eyes it
twists him a little half turn i mean
look how he lands it's perfect almost
yeah dead straight so actually doing a
flip gives you more control and is in a
way easier for a professional than if
you tried to not move at all
rick charles is two and a half points
out of first
[Laughter]
so you guys said the last guy was cool
how would the other guy does it
wait there's another dude doing this
rick winter's like i'm gonna do this
backwards oh my god dude oh yeah do it
blind rick you psycho
[Applause]
who needs to look
dang
that's terrifying that's so much hang
time
boom there it is
dude what does it take to get a 10.
one of my favorite moments in any stun i
think all the stun performers probably
relate to whether you're doing something
kind of fun or something that's going to
hurt or something that's just like
extreme is this you're like three
you're like all right never start to
calculate am i here or do i need to be
where i need to be and two you know and
then all kinds all right sense in the
world starts to fade you lose cameras
you know you lose sight of all the other
stuff
one you're like here i go and then
somewhere between one in action is this
like you have to let everything go like
especially on the ones that are gonna
hurt
your body is like
made to protect you so you have to
somehow like disconnect with your
natural instinct to protect yourself in
order to get the shot especially because
you know like if you try to do it wrong
and you cheat it and you're gonna end up
having to do it again and again and
again
[Music]
what's up guys i'm jordan and i wanted
to talk to you about our sponsor today
vessy now why is everyone wearing these
shoes around here everyone everyone in
the studio they're rocking vest scenes
i'll tell you why besties are 100
waterproof they're stylish they're
affordable they're reliable you can use
besties for any occasion i personally
use mine to work out every single day
but you can also one wheel down a cliff
family christmas cards noodling jumping
in puddles together did i mention
noodling they're sustainably made using
less material less water waste no animal
byproducts so they're vegan they're made
from dymatex a dual climate net that
keeps you cool in the summer and warm in
the winter you can just rinse them with
water or toss in the washing machine i
know what you're thinking i need this
video to be over so i can go order my
pair of besties right now right so click
the link in the description below go to
bessie.com corridor crew and you can get
25 off of each pair of vessies 25 that's
literally like five pumpkin spice lattes
25 off of each pair of vessies your
whole family can be jumping in mud
puddles by the end of the week now
that's a family christmas card i don't
think a stuntman at uh react himself has
ever been my palm sweaty really straight
up yeah that high dive
oh boy nightmares are coming back
tonight
sure dude jesse thank you for coming out
man oh yeah thank you freaking awesome
so you got a book how to become a stunt
man how to become a stuntman.com and
there's a lead in there to a five-week
stunt training course if you guys are
interested in learning more about stunts
and want to actually pursue it as a
career
definitely go check it out well jesse
thanks so much for being on our show
clint it's been good to see you again
yeah good to be back what's going on
yeah youtube.com
right
yeah come on over youtube.com slash
punisher hang out learn some cg stuff
cool well thanks for watching everybody
see you in the next one